Let's summarize what we need to do.
The AV audio recorder is going to call
out the record sounds view controller
once the recording is complete.
And the file is saved right
to this function here.
We need to den call the stop
recording segway and so
on along with it the path
to the recorded sound.
If we had this line to the audio
recorder did finish recording function
that you see here.
We can call the stop recording
segway and send it the URL for
the recording file is located.
Notice something here, the audio
recorder did finish recording function,
receives a flag, indicating if saving
the recording was successful or not.
We should read that flag and
if saving the recording failed, we can
print out a message to the console.
I'm going to switch out
the single call here.
For an if statement.
If the flag is true then I'm
going to perform the segue.
And if it's false,
I'm going to print out saving of
the recording failed out to the console.
Now we just need a way to inform
the play sound's view controller
it just received the URL
of the recorded audio.
Lucky for us,
UI Kit makes that fairly simple as
I'll show you in the next step.